cada segundo millones de litros de agua
son descargados esta madrugada la presa
hidroeléctrica de nuevo kahoffka quedó
parcialmente destruida una escena que
los ucranianos temían por encima de todo
esta gigantesca estructura de casi 4
kilómetros de largo y 16 metros de ancho
herencia de la era soviética desempeñaba
un papel estratégico situada en el río
nieper también abastecía la Península de
crimea más al sur su destrucción también
Podría tener consecuencias para el
sistema de refrigeración de la central
nuclear de saporicha en kievel
presidente selenski convocó una reunión
de emergencia de Consejo de Seguridad
acusó a Moscú de estar detrás de la
destrucción
la destrucción de la presa de la central
hidroeléctrica de Jacob ka no ha hecho
más que confirmar al mundo entero que
los terroristas rusos deben ser
expulsados de todos los rincones del
territorio ucraniano no podrán detener a
Ucrania ni con agua ni con misiles ni
con nada en la región de en parte de la
cual está controlada por Moscú las
fuerzas prorrusas afirman que la
estructura fue destruida por múltiples
ataques ucranianos la urgencia ahora es
evacuar las localidades que podrían
inundarse muy rápidamente 80 localidades
entre ellas gerson están amenazadas
en pocas horas el nivel del agua
alcanzará una fase crítica la evacuación
de personas para salvar las zonas ha
comenzado les insto a que lleven solo lo
esencial y esperen a los autobuses de
evacuación Así mismo a los residentes de
la parte izquierda del río les pido que
hagan a todo lo posible por salvar sus
vidas y abandonen inmediatamente las
zonas de riesgo
en 2022
era posible hablando de una catástrofe a
gran escala